this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
happy anniversary ryan oh dude what did
you get me it's our 10th anniversary
yeah yeah and so the the gift for a
10-year anniversary yeah
is ten did you give me a ten tie clip
i got you ten tie clips ten tin tie
clips
that's really good alliteration there oh
happy anniversary y'all uh this
is we're putting out a bonus episode so
it's coming out today
sunday december 13th tomorrow december
14th
marks our 10 year anniversary
of the minimalists.com it's gone by
very quickly when i stopped to like
think about
the last 10 years a lot has happened
yeah
um but it's gone by so quick that like i
feel like i'm gonna blink and
i'm gonna be 50 and it'll be our 20-year
anniversary i agree
it's kind of like the high school
reunion remember like oh the 10-year
reunion yeah but i look forward to this
one though right
[Laughter]
so true so um you and i are going to go
in depth this week on
uh patreon on the minimalist private
podcast for some reason
i said we're going into debt this week
no we're definitely we are
so uh all right so we're going to this
week's patreon we did a three hour
maximal episode really breaking down
the last 10 years so if you're
interested in that the minimalists.com
support you can check out our private
podcast this week
but here on this bonus episode or this
extra episode
actually we have two episodes coming out
this weekend extra
we have two episodes coming out this
week we have uh this one
on sunday and then tuesday we're doing a
quarantine conversation
sort of amalgamation of some of our
favorite quarantine conversations
that are coming out we've done 50 of
those over on the private podcast but
you're going to get three of them
on tuesday in one podcast episode plus
some other stuff
as well but uh before we get into some
of
our questions that we have today ryan
yeah let's just say that it
is not just our anniversary but it now
is the time for less always
it's hanukkah oh yeah what'd you get me
oh i just i'm re-gifting these tie clips
that someone
you gave me happy hanukkah y'all to our
jewish listeners uh by the way what was
what were some of your favorite
minimalist moments over the last decade
we've been doing the podcast for five
years now
the wholeminimalists.com for the last 10
years
let us know on social media we're at the
minimalists wherever you follow us on
social media or you can send us a text
message as well
937-202-4654
those texts go literally to both of our
phones we respond to as many people as
we can some of you
we even respond to on the podcast
speaking of text messages ryan i went
out to twitter and i went out to our
text message
list the people who text us questions
regularly
and gathered together some questions
about our 10-year anniversary
cool so i thought maybe we would start
with a wren's question
okay so iren wants to know does it feel
like 10 years or more or less oh i kind
of already answered that on accident my
answer to this is is yes it depends on
on
the angle from which we look at it yeah
it's weird looking at it on hindsight
or looking at it with hindsight i
totally agree it's like i said in the
beginning it's like i
it feels like we've done a lot so it
feels like we've definitely done 10
years worth of work
yeah yeah um but yeah it didn't feel
like 10 years it feels like an
intentional 10 years and the way i think
about it is
i can tell you what we did every year of
the last decade
before that when we were in the
corporate world for a dozen years
you can't go back and say hey hey josh
what'd you do in 2004
no idea i don't know how 2004 was
different from 2005 was different from
2007.
it was just one decade of more i feel
like 2004 is isn't that when he became
manager i don't know
that's my point yeah manager of what
right who gives a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
jay youngward has a question for us
what if anything did you
use to believe about minimalism that you
no longer do
well this was difficult for me ryan
because the last two months in
particular
so you and i haven't uh oh by the way we
should say this now
this is our last podcast that we're
going to record in
this studio that's right we're getting
kicked out yeah our our building is
closing that we're in
yeah but we found a new studio space so
don't worry uh next year
we already recorded a few additional
podcasts so you're going to see the
studio a few more
times this beautiful beautiful studio
we've been in for the last three years
we found a new studio space and in fact
on our youtube channel i think we're
going to do a
video tour of the old space cool new
space and us moving
into our beautiful new studio it is
aggressively minimalist
sweet i even got you a straight jacket
thank you it's like a padded room it
looks it's a white padded room
hanukkah keeps on giving
[Laughter]
it's made of 10. it's in straight jacket
so jay young words question anything you
used to believe
that you no longer believe about
minimalism well i'm just gonna take
minimalism out of there for a moment
because minimalism has helped free up
the space create
some space for me to to rethink about my
life to think about my life in
in new and interesting ways especially
over the last decade
however the last two months in
particular you know i ended up in the
hospital a couple months ago
october um in the emergency room now i
haven't been in the emergency room since
like the early 90s i'm not just the
person who goes to the emergency room
right
and since then i've done a lot of
reflecting on
the last 40 years but the last 10 years
in particular
and so what i really like about this
question is my answer today
in december is different from what it
would have been back in september or
a year ago or five years ago i'm going
to read something that i wrote down
for this and so we can just go through a
few of these things this is probably my
longest answer of all this but
i'm i'm fascinated to have this
conversation with you right now ryan
because these are some things you and i
haven't really talked about
uh yet and so this will be the first
time we're
beginning to even approach these topics
and what i'll say is over the course of
the next year i'm probably going to go
in depth
on the private podcast on these sort of
try and work out some of these ideas i'm
still figuring a lot of these things out
and so yeah what i've noticed is
i've had you know there was that anticip
unanticipated chaos of ended up in the
hospital right
and over the last few months um i sort
of peeked behind this
curtain that was open for me and i
realized that
most of life is chaos and also
this is going to sound like hyperbole
but it's it's really not
i'm saying this and i mean it we've been
lied to
our entire lives well sure and and
by by just about everyone i think it's
because of tradition though
i think tradition is yeah it's tradition
to just lie to
everyone oh yeah but also like tradition
and sense that we've been acculturated
right no
yeah and so let me just talk about a few
things
that i understand now that i didn't
understand maybe two or three months ago
i now understand that my beliefs my
opinions
and also the methods or
methodologies the modalities the how
to's the solutions
whatever you want to call it those
things my beliefs my opinions my
solutions
my advice um cloud the truth
so wait are you saying that we've been
lying to people for the last 10 years
well a lie implies intention right so no
no but i am saying i'm rethinking some
things that i have
that have been what i thought was useful
to me but may have not been useful
to me in the past so let me say this
um beliefs opinions methods
cloud the truth ego we know ego
it's not a bad thing i want to be clear
about that
it is not a good thing either that's
those are value judgments right
but but ego also hope
this word hope isn't like that's one of
the
the nicest things you can you can say is
you know in fact barack obama uses on
his posters right
hope and change it is a good thing hope
right
i don't think so i think hope tethers us
to a future and whenever we're tethered
to a future
we we crave we're suffering
and so i have been writing about this
recently at the minimalists
you've seen some of the stuff i've put
out there you know this whole time
for the last 10 years yes people have
accused us of being monks
and i think they might be right now
because this is a very monk-like
approach
well it depends what you mean by monk
right i think i think that part of that
is also a lie
untethering from any
expectation or any
how about just untethering yeah right i
was gonna say from any feeling
whatsoever but i know that's not what
you're saying
but you are talking about untethering
from a lot of different
feelings let's maybe we call something
else we call it detachment right
yeah and and i'm talking about healthy
detachment
yeah uh habit change this is something
else that my mind is rapidly changing
about
and i know james clear would not be
happy to hear this
but i think habits are nonsense
and i think i've always thought this and
it's just really solidifying in me
now i'm gonna write about this so so
stay tuned if you subscribe to our free
newsletter at the minimalist you'll be
the first to hear about these
these things but i've been writing a lot
about like i wrote about success
recently how all success is failure yeah
and you can find that essay shawn put a
link to that in the show notes if you
don't mind
um i wrote an essay about attachment
called letting go
is not something you do it's something
you stop doing
and so so we'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well
and then what was the other one that was
out there recently sean
um the letting go one we did the
um oh
success is failure anyway i'll think
about it you can check out the
the recent archives over the
minimalists.com those essays are all
free to look at but
i'm going to be writing about habit
change because here's i think habit
change actually covers up problems
and and so i'll riff on this really
quickly sure and then you and i can talk
about it more maybe we can even bring
someone like matiavella
or james clear on the podcast these
these habit change proponents
and uh we can have a healthy discussion
around uh this stuff because i'm open to
having my mind
change some more but here's why i think
habit change is a problem i think it
focuses on the solution
and thus doesn't address the actual
problem the example i used in that essay
that sean really liked i used a couple
actually
but but one was if the chair that
you're if ryan you were sitting that
chair right there right
if that chair were to catch fire right
you wouldn't need to change your habits
to act because you would deal with the
problem you also
wouldn't have you wouldn't need the fire
safety manual to figure out what to do
yeah now you and i have been saying this
stuff for years
we've said like hey you're not going to
hear me and ryan talk about the 67 ways
to declutter your closet
right the how to stuff is less
interesting
to us because if you don't understand
the why two side of
things which is really the problem if
you don't understand the problem all of
these solutions
don't matter by the way if your closet
is cluttered you do not have a
a decluttering tip deficit that's not
your problem
right everyone knows how to declutter
the key is why to declutter
so we've been saying that for a long
time it's just reframing that to
understand that like habit change is not
as powerful
as a deep understanding of what the
problem is because if you fundamentally
understand the problem and the severity
of that problem
you'd understand that chairs on fire you
are going to you're going to get up you
don't need some five-step plan you don't
need instructions to make it happen
you are going to figure it out
immediately you're going to act on it
yeah these are all interesting
perspectives man i mean
i don't know if i'm there uh
like emotionally but i do certainly see
the side or the the the perspective
you're taking
something really a side i guess um yeah
i mean there's a balance
it's like i mean think about cpr classes
it's like a paramedic has to go to you
know
classes to learn cpr there's like a
habit that's involved
someone drops on the ground although i
mean i know you know
we've got this there's a whole other
conversation about someone being revived
and if they need to be revived or not
and
how much damage but let's just leave
that out let's just talk about bringing
someone back
if that person doesn't know how to do
cpr in that moment
then there could be some consequences
for it it's the same thing with someone
who's working out it's like
someone like you know let's say they're
just extremely overweight
they want to you know they want to eat
healthier they want to exercise
um there is a fundamental problem that
i'm sure they understand
but without any type of
direction it just sometimes it just
doesn't go as smoothly i guess all
i'm just what i'm really trying to get
at is i feel like there's a balance with
everything that you're talking about
when it comes to hope when it comes to
habits
uh when it comes to advice when it comes
to these boundaries
i mean one thing that i've learned over
the last 10 years
is that those things are constantly
shifting so for me it's not about
cutting them out of my life but it's
looking at all of those things
and saying are these really serving me
right now because sometimes habits can
get in the way
so or thinking about doing the habit can
get in the way sometimes
uh hope you know hope hope can turn into
hopelessness you know
uh so so yeah i mean for me the last
10 years the biggest things i have
learned is that you can't rely
on hope you can't rely on habits you
can't rely
on uh what else did you say hope
habits bunch of things here opinions
beliefs yeah opinions beliefs uh
boundaries yeah i mean like those are
things that
help the k the chaos that we live
well let's talk about that word yeah
help i don't want to help people
um okay expound
so i want to speak the truth mm-hmm
right yeah i think once you don't think
that helps people i i don't care if it
does
and what i'm saying is uh if it helps
people
then so be it yeah i understand right
if it doesn't it's not going to help
everyone but hold on
the desire to help is all caught up in
ego
the wanting to help someone is
fundamentally a part of the ego and
that's
ryan that's not good or bad you got to
get that out of your head
oh yeah i'm not saying no no no and by
the way balance
that's a fancy word for mediocrity
okay i disagree but i i see what it's
not good that's not good or bad
and so balance it's okay to be mediocre
it
is something if you want to be mediocre
at it right
and and you're right um understanding
how to do something like the the
paramedic
basic recipes do help us through
elementary
tasks and that's what we've talked about
over the last 10 years is really sharing
a recipe
right and so a recipe is a great analogy
because if you want to cook a meal
then a recipe is going to help you with
that oh and by the way if you live in a
different part of the world the recipe
is going to have to be cooked a little
bit differently you know what i'm saying
with altitude or
yeah whether it's humid you know what
i'm saying right but it's not gonna
regardless of that my point is that a
recipe isn't going to make you gordon
ramsay though
right right and and so um if
if completing a elementary task
and mediocrity is okay for me i'm a
mediocre cook right and i'm okay with
sure it's not that's not a bad thing it
just is i don't have desire to become a
great
cook right yeah and so um yes i have
i have the balance there but like i
don't have greatness
in that sure i totally see what you're
saying with
balance can be a form of mediocrity yeah
yeah and so
just a couple of the things the value
judgments and these are some words that
i'm really working diligently to
actually i've set them down but because
i have such the habit
of picking them up i still use these
words all the time you and i were having
this conversation
yesterday so right wrong good bad should
shouldn't these are all moralizing
constructs
that they actually prevent me from
asking
the deeper questions the questions
that matter and
i think one of the things i've learned
most over the last
decade is solutions are
the problem and i've really i've
solidified that over there
every single solution is a problem
as solutions are the problems solutions
so
okay so so that's what i'm saying though
but like as a blanket statement
solutions in general are the problem
so yeah so so when i when i look at
a solution it's the the decluttering
thing we just talked about
people focus so much on decluttering
that you you don't get to the essence
of the problem we're worried more about
form than we are about the essence
of a thing and and so
the form is the the decluttering it's
the clean closet it's the tidy home it's
the container store it's
it's the you know the having the right
hangers and the right t-shirt
hey what couch do you have whatever
where'd you get your bookcase from
that is form what i'm concerned about is
the essence
and and so i'm less concerned about
the solutions because solutions are just
they're prescriptions they're band-aids
they're a they're but
a a opiate in a way it numbs the pain
it's funny because i'm trying to take
this as in a not good or bad way
right right but that's so hard right
yeah because everything you're using is
like pejorative
none we have been acculturated to
believe they're pejorative
and that's the problem when i say an
opiate
that's not a bad thing well i mean
suggesting that
right i mean suggesting that something
is like an opiate is suggesting that
you're addicted to something that is
really doesn't add value to your life i
wasn't suggesting addiction
and also addiction this is going to
sound strange addiction isn't a bad
thing right uh and that is hard to grasp
i'm gonna like i said i'm gonna
elaborate a lot more in writing on these
over the course of the next year but
also having more conversations deeper
conversations like this on patreon
uh let me just point out a few other
things that i i want to address we're
not going to go through
them right now yeah man i really yeah i
really i'm struggling to get there i
mean i i do see the perspective it's the
blanket statements that
it's hard for me to to like get there
with just a blanket statement of
every solution is actually the problem
or any solution is actually a problem
right and so so here's what is what is
then i mean
it becomes a semantic game right but
really what i'm saying
is exciting we focus on the solution
and when we do that we lose sight of the
problem so
that i get when we when we spend too
much time that's what i mean by a
problem
okay solution that's a problem right
again not good or bad but like a
solution to
we just had a call yesterday with uh uh
with our publishing company
about you know how we're going to
uh just stuff about the book and stuff
about the documentary
those are solutions so what to
uh i don't know to to
making sure that this is going as
smoothly as possible and all the ducks
are in a row so that when the book comes
out
people know what to expect we're setting
expectations for people
okay we're we are planning uh different
communications
leading up to the to the launch i mean
those are all i mean i'm just i'm just
i'm just trying i'm just trying to get a
problem so you're actually you're
illustrating
my point here is that when we're focused
on solutions oh yeah there is oh yeah
the solutions we have is no problem but
it's a but it's but it is a solution
a solution to what though it's a
solution to what are you solving
this is my point solutions rarely solve
anything
uh but it does prevent
if we didn't do if we didn't have that
call and if we didn't do anything
leading up to june
i guarantee we would look back and be
like oh [ __ ]
i didn't say don't do anything right
what i'm saying is don't
focus on actually not let me stop that's
now i'm giving advice i don't want to do
that either so so
no i'm just trying to get where you're
at with the solution because it is a
solution
to if we don't do something then
like if we don't do what we were
planning to do come june we would really
be like
what what just happened but i'm not
saying don't do anything
what i'm saying is when here's a good
word for it
see here is a useful word for this
conversation
um your face is useful
here's a useful word for the
conversation understanding
when you have a a true
understanding of whatever the problem is
the solutions appear
but when we start looking for solutions
five
step methods what are the seven habits
of a
highly effect effective people yeah
these
these don't do us justice
because they they skirt
the problem the actual problem but when
we have a
fundamental understanding and this is by
the way this isn't me saying you
should do something i don't need to do
so i'm not talking to you i'm saying
people at home i'm not saying you should
do something that
you shouldn't declutter your closet of
course
it makes sense for many people to
declutter their closets
what i'm saying is what makes more sense
is having a fundamental understanding of
why you're doing it i totally agree with
that
uh all right so let's say someone finds
out they have type 2 diabetes yes
and their doctor is like look you have
to stop eating
sugars and you have to exercise if you
don't do those two things
you're going to have type 2 diabetes
permanently and we're going to have to
like
you know give you whatever yeah i i can
answer this but ryan in a contract we
call this an opt-out clause
what does that mean uh where we're
you're finding a way to opt out of the
actual discussion oh
no no no i'm trying to unders i'm trying
to i'm trying to get a fundamental
understanding
of the solution is the problem think
what you're trying to say i
wanted to hold my tongue enough but i i
think what you're the better way to say
thanks to
what we're saying is the solution is
often
a distraction no the solution is
fundamentally a problem
and when you say when you say better way
that that
that also becomes a value judgment in a
way yeah and so
yeah i'm just trying i'm just trying to
and maybe i'll read some of the stuff
you write or actually
feel free to send me some of the i know
you've been reading a lot of monks and
buddhists and stuff
feel free to send me that i'm just
trying to like in that i'm trying to
look at how
someone with like type 2 diabetes well i
can let me let me talk to that right
sure and so if you understand the the
what is the solution there for them they
need insulin if someone has
if someone has type 2 diabetes they have
one of they have yeah they have
a few options exercise change your diet
or uh yes they can start taking insulin
right or there's like hemoglobin a1c
drugs they can take so like they can
start doing synthetic stuff or they can
start doing natural stuff
but the bottom line is if they do
nothing they die yes
so the problem is the problem is
condition that is dead someone has to
change what they're doing right
so i yeah so i do need to expand anymore
let's say let's say fundamentally
diabetes is not good or bad from a moral
perspective right there
diabetes diabetes is not immoral to have
trust is
dying isn't good or bad it's what
happens we all die eventually yeah
dying can be a phenomenal thing um and
and so we we can talk about that some
other time but
i'll just briefly address the diabetes
question
the point of what i'm saying here is if
you understand what the fundamental
problem is
is it's not just diabetes that's a label
right right the fundamental problem is
a series of habits that have led to
a decline in health and if you
understand that
intimately and everything that's behind
that problem the problem behind the
problem
the solutions won't matter because if
you understand that problem
you're going to fix the fix is the wrong
word
you're going to change your state
based on a deep understanding not based
on a
how many people do you know that that
changed their life off of a seven step
program long term it just doesn't
right that doesn't help what does help
wrong word again um what what is
illuminating
is the the understanding and that's if
you're in a 12-step program
it's a fundamental understanding of the
addiction which is the problem in your
life not the steps
that take care of it yeah we got a lot
more to talk about but we got some more
questions here let's
our friend tk coleman uh send us a
question on twitter
you guys are more popular than you were
10 years ago well maybe milburn is
what are some adjustments in your
lifestyle that be gay
that being popular has challenged you to
make okay so let me read that again
what are some adjustments in your
lifestyle that being popular has
challenged you to make
what's one thing about being popular
that you once believed but now realize
is a myth
what's one thing that hasn't got any
easier that's a lot of questions tk
yeah we love you so we'll go through
this real quick some adjustments to your
lifestyle that being popular has changed
you to make um here's a secret yeah if
you ever get
famous look like every other long-haired
bearded white guy
and no one will ever recognize you
that's what i've learned blend in people
recognize my forehead even when wearing
a mask
it's uh it's unfortunate you know i i
mean i haven't really changed my life
i i take pictures with people a lot more
now and and so that can be
i still give hugs yeah yeah i i mean i i
do that as well
um i mean you know with permission of
course yeah yeah and even now during
these times i'm like hey i'm typically a
hugger if you don't want to hug totally
understand happy to wave at you from six
to seven feet away i've had people turn
me down with the
like no i'm social distancing i'm like
all right yeah yeah of course you're
lost
so is there one thing uh being popular
about being popular that you once
believed but now realize
is a myth uh what's one thing that
hasn't gotten any easier
i mean i don't think things change that
much it's just like so
ryan you and i were popular before we
started the minimalists because
we were we led teams of people that's
popular
you're you're you're famous so i managed
150 retail stores at
uh my peak of the corporate world
and i say peak and quotes there um and
during that time we were really popular
to those
the people who worked in those stores
you were famous to the people
who worked in those stores this is not
different from that now except
i just don't know the people who
approach me
until i get to know them yeah i really
don't i don't feel like life is any
different
i mean it's better in the sense that
like my actions align with my values and
beliefs
has nothing to do with being famous but
there's nothing to do with being famous
like i mean i'm happy but it has nothing
to do with
like i couldn't even tell you any amount
of followers we have on anything on any
platform
yeah um yeah it's not relevant for you
yeah and to be honest i don't feel
famous i mean people will recognize me
yeah um well and because fame is like
you it feels ubiquitous
we don't have that yeah yeah yeah brian
walker has a question for us
what podcast episodes essays live events
are you most proud of
oh let's start with episodes okay
because that's different than live
events
yeah even though those are technically
episodes but they're live episodes so
let's just talk about
straight up episodes first what are your
favorite episodes your favorite is is a
better way to put it because he said are
you proud of and i try not to be proud
of these things
and i fail at that sometimes
um so oh that was the other essay right
success is failure
the solution is the problem and then
letting go isn't something you do it's
something you don't do yeah anyway
in terms of essays those three i just
mentioned are the three i'm
most uh or my three most favorites of
recent memory
yeah man i can tell like you uh
you're going through something kind of
exciting right now man
like really letting go of outcomes
and um i don't know man
it's but it's funny though because like
it's
like i feel pretty chill all the time
yeah like i don't really
well i aspire to have your level of of
but but i do attach to some certain
outcomes
right yeah and so i i don't aspire
actually that's that's the
wrong framing but what i'm saying is
that i i see that and i'm like oh
ryan has a healthy level of detachment
from certain things from other things
you you don't obviously yeah um and and
so
yes the we we have this new film coming
out the trailer's out right now by the
way
uh lessonsnow.com you can find it thank
you the film is called lesson now it
comes on netflix january 1st thank god
for matt diabella i know
he did it again so even though people
will give you and i credit for it
again yes and um but i don't have
so before i would have had some sort of
attachment to an outcome with that
but we made that and now it's it's going
to be out there on january 1st
and that's wonderful and and
i felt compelled to do it but i don't
i don't have an attachment to any
particular outcome with that and by the
way netflix helps with that because they
don't share the specific numbers anyway
so
what if i said well i need all 194
million netflix households to watch this
that's my outcome
yeah well i couldn't even prove it
either way yeah
man maybe this is an offline
conversation and you let me know
but speaking of the outcomes like with
the book
you've been able to let go of any
outcome with that
yeah or like or maybe you're working
towards it well yeah and so
this is something i'm saying because i
don't have an ex i don't have an
expectation
for like book sales but i do have an
expectation
and maybe you can help me let go of this
during this podcast of the effort
that we as a team including with our
publisher put into
making sure that this book reaches as
many people as possible i think teams
are crap
too but we'll talk about them in a
different podcast
and uh i mean i really want to dive into
that so but
so let's talk about so we have a new
book coming out this summer it's called
love people use
things and you and i yeah i have to have
a healthy detachment from this one
here's why because as
uh my my brain is updating
i i start to look at the things that are
in that book that isn't even out there
yet
what are you on now ios like 12 that
something yeah
no i'm a samsung it's uh 7 3
b quirks oh
congratulations these terrible uh model
numbers
sorry shout out to our android users
yeah um
no anyway so the outcome yeah so here's
the thing i have to be
detached from it because if any
if i aspire to do anything it's to think
differently
from my previous self until until i get
to the fundamental truth
and i think there are a lot of truths in
this book and it's our best written book
it
it contains um
that has resonated with me what's that
the truth fundamental truth
yeah because if you can live a
fundamental truth
then i do see where the solutions start
disappearing well let's talk about that
real quick because so
a moment ago i talked about beliefs were
something that i'm beginning to change
yeah for a decade you and i have said
well make sure you you well this and we
give advice which is
uh crap and and so like well i don't
want to keep giving advice right i want
to i
i instead of giving advice i'd rather
speak the truth
sure and if people get something from
that now you and i have said this for
years
if they get something from our recipe
applies to their own life great yeah
but i don't want to say you should take
my recipe and do something with it right
of course and the same is true with the
letting go i'm not saying you should let
go if you decide
that's something you want to do is let
go of some outcomes
then so be it if you decide you want to
cling with
uh abandon then so be it
and and what the thing i've learned
about attachment is attachment always
equals misery always that
someone reached out to me on twitter
recently i said well isn't there
what about healthy attachments and and i
agree
and so my thought is what if you what if
you change the word attachment instead
of attachment you said clingy because
it's the same thing
what about healthy clinging what about
because clinging is
craving craving is suffering and if
you're
suffering what about healthy suffering
well that
that doesn't that's counterintuitive
right it's oxymoronic
yeah and and so i'm not saying that
suffering is bad i'm not saying
attachment is
bad i'm not saying they're immoral
things
what i'm saying is that if you don't
want to get dragged
you better if you don't want to get drag
dragged let go you can tweet that
podcast sean it's good
it makes me think about like uh like
someone who
has maybe like fallen in love they get
attached and then that person they fall
in love with
um does whatever and like breaks their
heart
yeah suffering uh
it's it's interesting because like i
i don't know if i've been there
personally but i've seen people where
they will then find another relationship
yeah and then they
they'll ruin it because they refuse to
get attached and they refuse to like
let themselves be involved with that
person because they're scared of getting
hurt and then eventually
the person i'm thinking of specifically
was able to like
basically accept the fact that i got one
or two options
i can like live a in a relationship
that i really just feel okay with or i
could risk it all
put it all in black and fall in love
again
and be attached with the that's not love
with the um with the possibility of
essentially getting their
heart broken again um
yeah i i'm not saying attachment is love
no attachment's suffering
attachment prevents one from truly
loving
okay that's that's going to be a deep
conversation
yeah it will be i mean i yeah because
it's because it's like with mariah
do i need mariah to be happy no but god
dude life is so much better with her in
my life okay
and i am attached to living a very a
meaningful life
i understand yeah all right let's do one
more question here
let's see let's uh what what looks good
janine yeah let's look at janine's
question all right let's look at
janine's
when you look back at yourselves in 2010
and compare you to yourselves now what's
the biggest difference as individuals
and as the minimalist well it's by far
my hair
yeah look at pictures of ryan from 2012
it looks like my son
if you want to see my kid all grown up
[Laughter]
young ryan plays self
[Laughter]
actually we in the new film uh lessons
now we had to have a young ryan for one
of the recreation scenes what was his
name
jett uh he looked like a young ryan they
did such a good job where
you were painting with your father you
played your father yeah
which you kind of i mean you look like
if your dad you look like the movie star
version of your dad
i'm sorry that's the best insult i've
ever gotten wait no
nothing is the best and nothing is
insulting that was a very appropriate
comment josh thank you
let's talk about this uh uh compare
yourselves
compare yourselves from 2010 to now
first off janine comparison
is the killer of all joy i think
comparisons a
i think it's a it's a sort of low-grade
mental illness
yeah yeah yeah and and so i'm not going
to compare myself now to then i mean
obviously uh i i know more
um but it's
we certainly can't equate the two right
because we are radically different
people from what we were
and i don't know why this is and sean
you can maybe talk to this but in fact
our maximal episode this week is called
it's three hours long it's called as the
decade fades because
uh my novel that i wrote in my mid-20s
was called as a decade fades and i
actually finished it when i was 29
and at 29 10 years ago a decade ago
and now i'm at another point where a
decade is fading
i'll be 40. another decade fades yeah
and so
and so here we are we've had this decade
of less right
of of the minimalist stuff but now as i
go into this new decade of my
my 40s i've i'm beginning to
to realize that
what is what matters to me is
fundamentally is
the truth and to get there i
i find it necessary to
untether and also the loving thing that
we mentioned earlier and we've got to do
a whole episode about this ryan
about deep love i i think that it's not
possible to truly love someone
if attachment is involved and
it's funny how you're really attached to
convincing people
that attachment oh i don't want to
convince you i i absolutely don't want
to convince you okay
uh i i want to speak the truth right and
how attached you are to speaking the
truth about attachment
you're very attached to that right now
no i i'm i am
i continue to pick things up right sure
and
that's you know that's the story of our
the last 10 years really man
we've just been picking stuff up and
putting it down and and so
what i'm really trying to do now is
put those things down that aren't
serving me in fact do the opposite i
think beliefs
so that's the beliefs thing i was going
to say for the last 10 years we've said
well yeah align your actions with your
with your values and beliefs
no no no no i don't have advice on that
anymore but i can say this here's an
observation about my
my own life beliefs simply cloud the
truth
beliefs do not require the truth beliefs
aren't wrong
we all have the vast majority virtually
everyone has
their own beliefs but i'm working to
detach from those beliefs to let go of
those beliefs
because they might prevent me
from seeking that which is true
ryan we've got a bunch of listener tips
to get into today also an added value
segment just a quick reminder
to join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week that's right
we release a second private podcast
episode every week on patreon that's
one free minimal episode every tuesday
you're actually getting two minimal
episodes this week for free so the
minimum episode that's the one you're
listening to
right now plus a completely separate
long-form maximal episode
every thursday which means that if
you're not a
private podcast supporter you're
literally missing more than half of our
show and that's not good or bad
you're just missing out and uh that's
yeah
you're allowed to do that absolutely so
visit the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show
100 advertisement free
that's the minimalists.com support ryan
what else you got for us this week well
josh has finally started his only fans
uh
account
and that's where you get the other half
of uh the minimalists uh uh
uh creations no well i would say other
one-third
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right man uh no i got here for us
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners let's check them out
hi this is jenna from salt lake city i
just had a quick comment about your last
episode about
giving and gifts as someone who likes to
make things
as gifts for other people i really
appreciate
how you guys approach the thank you very
much this is so much time that i'm not
going to use this would you like it back
i think that's probably probably the
best way at least
i've found to handle gifts that other
people give me that i can't use or
for other people to handle gifts that
i've made for them but they aren't going
to use
um it's a very thoughtful and it
respects the time
and energy that was put into the gift
without um
accepting the the guilt or the necessity
of keeping it
hi my name is stephanie i'm calling from
michigan and i'm calling with a comment
for
two maybe three suggestions the first
one is there's
a website in an app called think dirty
where it will list ingredients of makeup
and kind of give a clean score based on
their chemicals and everything that's
inside them
so if you're looking for a clean
alternative you can scan the makeup
products that you
already have and kind of either score
if you're looking for more better
alternatives with the better ingredients
they'll give you alternatives listed and
then you can actually shop
right from their app as well my second
suggestion would also be they have
called
good on you it's where they list
ecologically responsible and animal
friendly
alternative to makeup and clothing so
you can search on their website if
you're looking for
you know lipstick primer foundation
everything like that
and my third suggestion would be is my
own little personal rule is i
typically have one quality makeup item
for each you know specific area so if
i'm looking for
eyeliner i have one quality eyeliner i'm
looking for mascara
i have one vascular tube at a time so
this helps to cut down on my makeup that
way i don't have
you know 17 different eyelash and um
eyeshadow palettes as well
all right y'all for our added value
segment today we're going to play you
out at the end of this episode with a
song don't yell at me podcast sean
uh shout out to i think it's amanda on
ig instagram um she sent me this
song and said hey this is like a a
minimalist punk
song oh wow and i listened to it it's a
band called valley heart and the song is
called
crave it's from their album everyone
i've ever
loved and so the song is about craving
and really that's what our work has been
about and especially
i think over the next decade we're going
to be talking a lot more about
the fundamental problems like craving
and so we're going to dive a lot deeper
with you all in the future i
i i could see next year in particular we
got this film coming out this book
coming out
it's gonna be sort of a victory lap of
our last decade but then
as we as those things come out that's a
summation of where we were
i'm really excited about where we're
going because
we're going to speak the truth we're
going to have some difficult
conversations i think that stuff will
start on on patreon because
it's hard to have some of these
conversations and i'm looking forward to
arguing with you about some of it no i
do these are great convos no i agree
i agree and really like i want to get
there where you're at dude and the only
reason i bring up the what did you call
them
what clauses are they the opt-out
clauses right i mean i bring up opt-out
clauses because i want people to
understand
uh there's my attachment to wanting to
for people to understand
but no i but attachment too i just i
just don't wanna
i just know to every rule there's an
exception and the more there are
exceptions then it starts to become less
of a rule and that's where i'm trying to
get to like am i thinking of exceptions
or
am i actually like i'm trying to get to
the rule is really what i'm trying to
say
i think rules are crap too but we're
gonna have to we're at the table
it's a metaphor it's a metaphor um but
uh no man i look forward to having these
conversations and there's something else
i was gonna say that i forgot
continue well we got a right here right
now segment we should talk about what's
going on in the life of the minimalist
we already alluded to this but
les is now the trailer is out there
right now
less is now.com you can find it stay
tuned we're going to do a launch party
in january so the film comes out in
or on january 1st new year's day check
out the trailer right now
and stay tuned if you're on our email
list over at theminimalists.com
we're going to do an online launch party
we're also going to do
a socially distance in-person screening
somewhere details
coming on that soon we also might have a
few
socially distanced events in january as
well details
are forthcoming make sure you're on our
email list over at theminimalists.com
uh or you can be on our text list as
well
four six 937-202-4600 four we'll ever
send you spam or junk or advertisements
we will let you know
what we're up to you can follow the
minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram and apparently
only fans now
at the minimalists only fans.com
don't do that please come see one of our
live podcast shows visit the
minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists.com you can comment on this
episode youtube.com slash the minimalist
if you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists.com you'll also
receive
the simple sunday emails all the essays
i've been writing recently you'll get
those
for free in your inbox the
minimalists.com
and uh i hope you really enjoy this song
from oh hope that's the wrong word oh
still detaching from this it's funny how
semantics are we're acculturated right
yeah culture is a giant problem by the
way i remember what i was gonna i agree
uh i uh remember what i was gonna say
because for the last 10 years
to say that we haven't been speaking the
truth it's almost like
uh i didn't say that by the way right
but to to be like oh what we're gonna
start doing is speaking the truth
but for the last 10 years we i would say
we've been truthful
um but our truth has changed i guess
or the perspective on truth has changed
i don't think the truth changes
well no no i'm but but for you to say
like you know
we're gonna you know we have a lot of
exciting things coming up
we are gonna focus on speaking the truth
as if we haven't been focused on
speaking the truth
no no i i i have been but not to the
extent i'm going to be
and so there are there are layers to
this right
and so there's a truth beneath the truth
beneath the truth
and it's the it's the problem behind the
problem thing right
and so when your car breaks down
you can you know you you can
figure out how you're going to get it to
the gas station right
but fundamentally there's going to be an
actual problem that we need to address
once we get into the service center
right
and so what we've done is is we have
been
speaking the truth over the last decade
what i want to do is get to the the next
layer the truth behind the truth yes
yeah yeah i really do no i get that man
even with the car analogy because it
made me think like you know
let's say your tire pops because you
didn't change them like there's a
fun there's a truth under the truth of
like you've got to change your tires
more often right yeah yeah anyway well
here here's a song called crave from
valley hearts from their album everyone
i've ever loved if you leave here today
with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it